lo consideres en los países miembros de
la Organización de Estados Americanos
firmaron la declaración de Lima que
establece entre otros puntos la
importancia de colocar a las personas y
sus comunidades en el centro de las
políticas sobre desarrollo y la lucha
contra la discriminación el
empoderamiento y el autonomía de las
mujeres y los grupos tradicionalmente
excluidos de las estructuras políticas
de poder para alcanzar soluciones
efectivas y duraderas fortalecer la
gobernabilidad institucionalidad
democrática en los países de la región
promover y proteger los derechos humanos
de todas las personas para la existencia
de sociedades democráticas inclusivas
combatir la pobreza como la
manifestación más alta de la desigualdad
y la exclusión de amplios grupos de la
población condenar a toda exclusión y
especialmente cualquier tipo de
violencia por raza color sexo género
idioma o religión la quincuagésima
segunda asamblea de la oea culminó con
casi tres horas de retraso y con un
sabor amargo durante las plenarias
Bolivia criticó duramente al organismo
freymamani dice de Bolivia le pidió al
secretario general Luis almagro poner
fin a lo que denominó la hipocresía de
la oea así como a la politización Pues
según el Vice canciller boliviano el
organismo pasa su peor época Pues a su
criterio existe intereses parciales y
mezquinos